la quatrième édition du martinique surf
pro débute ce week-end ce sera à
basse-pointe une quatrième édition qui
vient confirmer que notre île la
martinique dispose de sacré potentiel
pour faire parler d'elle et là en
l'occurrence à travers des sports
nautiques bonjour nicolas clémente et
aux journalistes vous êtes l'un des
organisateurs de cette manifestation
c'était un pari osé au départ ya une
première fois une seconde troisième
aujourd'hui la quatrième le martinique
surf pro devient vraiment une vitrine de
notre territoire à l'international oui
effectivement 150 millions de personnes
touchées en trois éditions
donc on parle de personnes cumulent donc
c'est quand même une belle performance
et qui prouve que nos vagues
martiniquaise ont fait le tour du monde
et voilà pourquoi ça n'avait pas été
fait plus tôt et il fallait une réelle
volonté de montrer le potentiel comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure qui existe
sur notre territoire c'est vrai que le
surf est inscrit dans l'adn des
martiniquais à travers le waf l'eau
après sa discipline qui est resté
longtemps mal connu alors pari gagné
tourisme sportif tourisme nautique c'est
une piste à creuser davantage au delà de
ce martinique sur ce projet à oui
évidemment le main leurs fans et un
support je pense qu'il ya énormément de
jeunes de personnes qui ont plein de
projets intéressants il faudrait
accompagner dans ce sens qui pourrait
aider la martinique a rayonné autrement
que par les canaux classiques qu'on
connaît qui la positionne surtout en
concurrence avec d'autres territoires où
trouver beaucoup moins cher vous avez un
mot très intéressant qu'il faudrait
accompagner c'est peut-être là que le
bât blesse lorsqu'on est porteur de
projet comme celui que vous avez explosé
il ya une demi douzaine d'années c'est
vrai que ça n'a pas été facile
on s'est battu pour et on y est arrivé
jusqu'à présent c'est ce qu'il a fallu
qu est ce qu il a fallu comme
argumentation pour vous-même pour
poursuivre ce combat qu'il était
vraiment très très très loin d'être
gagné et avait déjà deux choses c'est
quand je disais tout à l'heure c'est une
discipline qui était très mal connue sur
ut3 29ème malgré le fait que c'est
quelque chose qui est historiquement
fait partie de notre patrimoine
les gens s'ils avaient une peur quand
même de la mer et donc quand on est
arrivé il fallait qu'on montre et qu'on
prouve qu effectivement il y avait des
factures étaient trois caves un
potentiel que c'était possible que c'est
une industrie qui pèse très lourd dans
le monde c'est plutôt c'est plus de 50
milliards de d'euros dans le l'industrie
du surf
aujourd'hui dans le monde donc c'est
vrai que moi je viens du marketing la
communication n'est quand même je suis à
des grandes compétences aussi dans
l'ordre dans tout ce qui est
organisation huilée l'autre co
organisateur de cet événement oui c'est
ça tout ce qui est financée et c'est
donc les deux réunis on a mis en fait
c'est de cette opération n'est
simplement que la mutuelle mutualisation
de savoie en faire un deux jeunes
martiniquais pas que nous et à d'autres
personnes aussi qui ont permis de
démontrer le potentiel qui existait est
d'arriver à ça n'a pas été si je le
répète ça a été très très très difficile
de démontrer le trio pour le potentiel
est question de territoire et le
valoriser vous aviez l'idée au départ qu
est-ce qu il ya quelqu un verrou à a dû
sauter pour que finalement tout
s'enchaîne jusqu'à gros succès qu'on
continue tant qu'on constate aujourd'hui
mais déjà la première chose c'est de
prouver que là il y avait une offre
touristique sur toute la côte nord
atlantique quétin j'allais quitter un
petit peu délaissé de ce côté là
complètement friche voilà pour ne pas
dire ça et que nos vagues constitue une
richesse
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait parce
qu'avant on avait plutôt tendance à se
battre contre l'environnement alors
qu'on peut totalement l'utiliser et le
convertir en faire quelque chose qui
rapporte et c'est vrai que ça a été très
très très compliqué de démontrer
démontrer cela c'est parce que
historiquement les gens avaient peur de
la mer quand on va sur l'emploi
constatée à les maisons sont tourner
plus vers les routes que vers l'océan
donc avait vraiment tout ça qu'il
fallait modifier transformé dans la
mentalité des gens vous parlez du bois
flou à cette pratique
on va dire quasiment en cessera qu'à
vite été remis un peu par l'image de ces
est conscient qu'ils attendaient
l'arrivée de cyclones professeur fait
par exemple sur les plages du diamant
soit aussi vous avez dû combattre ses
idées
bien sûr bien sûr tout ça ce sont des
idées reçues
parce qu'il faut savoir que dès ce n'est
pas forcément l'arrivée alors il est
certain que un cyclone va générer de la
houle mais bien souvent dans l'année et
à des rôles très puissante mais non liée
à l'arrivée un cyclone proche de la
caraïbe et c'est qui qui vont se
déverser qui ont fuité nos côtes et ça
nous empêche pas de nous élancer sur ses
vagues alors vous parlez de chiffre
d'affaires de 50 milliards de 50
milliards d'euros au niveau mondial
concernant le surf la martinique c'est
forcément quelques miettes ça représente
à peu près combien travers sur
martinique sur frau la martinique shirt
pour juste pour donner un ordre de
grandeur
le prize money parce qu'on est sur du
sport professionnel donc c'est la mise
qui va être éclaté sur le podium une
partie des compétiteurs et deux cent
cinq mille dollars cette année donc
aujourd'hui dans la caraïbe ya très peu
voire pas d'opération de cette ampleur
est-ce que nous sommes observés à
travers cette caraïbes à ce que les
autres pays de la zone ne regarde un
regard de cette manifestation
bien sûr il ya beaucoup de yade pas mal
de surfeurs professionnels en guadeloupe
il y en a quelques-uns à saint martin à
seebach y en a beaucoup à porto rico
il y en a pas mal aussi en jamaïque donc
effectivement c'est une opération très
attendue par la carie mais surtout par
le monde entier puisque ces 25 nations
qui seront représentés cette année à
travers 160 compétiteurs et puis surtout
172 très exactement et puis surtout
l'édition 2018 est ouverte aux femmes et
ça aussi c'est une première
oui chaque année à l'organisation a pour
but de proposer une expérience nouvelle
et qui permet aussi à un autre organe
autre événement de grandir donc cette
année la nouveauté c'est le rajout de la
compétition féminine
alors aujourd'hui le martinique sur frau
on va dire il est inscrit dans dans le
calendrier est ce que vous êtes sûr au
moment où nous parlons de pouvoir faire
autant que ce que vous avez déjà fait
c'est à dire quatre éditions
mais est-ce que c'est à dire que déjà là
nous avons doublé le format de
l'événement c'est à dire que nous avons
rajouté une compétition féminine au
format masculin classique
donc on a doublé l'opération c'est sûr
que la world surfing pour répondre à la
question qu'est la fédération mr
souhaite l'établir de manière permanente
sur le territoire pourquoi parce que la
qualité de l'organisation était seul et
la qualité de nos vagues a été salué la
qualité aussi de l'accueil contrairement
à ce qu'on pense a été saluée c'est à
dire que je comprends qu'ils pensent
quoi à propos de la qualité de l'accueil
qui m'a écouté un jeu régulièrement
j'entendais qu'effectivement les
martiniquais ne sont pas des gens
accueillants qui peuvent être entre
guillemets mali etc
mais nous leur tour que nous avons des
internationaux c'est que ce sont des
gens agréables gentil on peut dire aux
petits soins
et d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de surfeurs
qui ont fait le choix non dit non non
les différentes offres d'hébergement
proposé d'être chez l'habitant pour être
carrément contact de la culture et des
saveurs culinaires etc
alors justement qui bénéficient
principalement dire tomber du martinique
sur ce son lit
les logements du nord atlantique ce sont
les hôtels et les restaurants de de la
zone ce sont les habitants de la zone ou
bien c'est c'est toute la martinique
alors moi j'ai envie de dire martin qui
sera projeté un projet martinique qui va
se dérouler dans le nord atlantique à
travers la commune de base compte donc
quand on est à 160 compétiteurs donc on
peut parler l'impact direct qui débarque
sur le territoire accompagné de deux à
trois personnes
donc ça on him on a une idée peu près du
nombre d'arrivants qui vont consommer de
l'aérien de la restauration de la
location de voiture etc
on voit déjà l'impact économique direct
que ces arrivants peuvent générer sur un
territoire après l'antique shirt pro
c'est une organisation qui sollicitent
100 entreprises martiniquaises pour la
mise en place
donc c'est à peu près 200 personnes
pendant le mois de l'événement qui
travaillent de manière indirecte sur
l'opération entreprise est ce que les
politiques suivent les communautés
d'agglomération est ce que la ctm vous
suit particulièrement l'office le comité
martiniquais du tourisme tout le monde
regarde cette manifestation avec un
disque dubitatif au belize yvon
franchement alors il ya blé ya beaucoup
de choses qui ont changé par rapport aux
autres années c'est à dire que
effectivement nous sommes plus écoutés
il ya plus d'engagement au niveau d'un
certain collective cette année au
sérieux quoi on nous sommes pris au
sérieux mais est-ce que ça reste
toujours très compliqué ça reste
toujours très compliqué à les
problématiques que tous les
organisateurs connaissent ces
problématiques de délai le versement de
d'organisation on est sur une opération
aux antilles en flic donc c'est qu'il
est l'équivalent de la nba de ce que
l'est est là mais nba pour le basket est
ce que la fifa pour le football
donc on répond à des cahiers des charges
très très lourd donc en termes
d'organisation nous avons besoin aussi
de sécurité donc c'est très très
compliqué même s'il y a une volonté
d'accompagnement de ce projet alors nous
capables de matinée sur frau nicolas
clémente et minier a fait deux soeurs
scolaire que d'autres aient développé
n'y en a fait d'eux de tradition que je
les respecte et là aussi c'est des
barricades et que d'autres faire pousser
aussi
ah oui prix mais bien nous fait puni
colère au chili c'est que déjà à la base
pente à six mains nues donc moi mais
pays nous nous amusons nous à nous aimer
pop nous a donc sinon m et pop noise
prime binding effet scénique est
diffusée discipline à battre ou non
jusqu'à avant et qu'elle existerai t
tournoi mais étaient en était fait mais
été fait mais la new river nous prions
association 2009 nous décidons nous
confesse à battre parce que tout le
monde n'est douanes pratiquer bas et à
la coloc a pris par contre si les
collègues notamment alors nous dit qu'on
nous de nous comment s'est développée
sera créé sur scolaire par côté le nom
pour vous montrer ces moments-là que you
pay utiliser long may you and you magna
pour utiliser du crédit qui ont la
monnaie pour sa vie et
donc nous épuiser collège ado non là bas
ni engloutir mike a bénéficié des
activités à nous créions leurs activités
acquises sur fascination donc à nous
contacter et pis tous ces organismes
d'insertion kignan en clientèle les
jeunes andy en situation difficile que
nous capot mais à travers discipline
tabou llopis a bénéficié de type
bien-être et du valais sur flop et deux
mots ce cas précis meilleur dacquois
tout cas fait combien d'ados démarche la
sillonnent la capote d'inimitable
peut-être que mon lait même voie mais ça
ça nous les faits c'est vraiment diffusé
discipline en a donné question parce
qu'on était tous très peu de temps
nicolas clémente et combien moins
qu'elle paie suivent en direct evènement
tard puisque ce journal au monde puisque
une kenyan direct à l'internet cas
permettent nous dit ouais événement
thann pour tricoter dans le monde et
puis notre cas il trouver toutes ces
informations les martinique la première
merci beaucoup nicolas clameur qui monte
d'être venu avec ton rappelle que le
martinique sur au quatrième édition
commence ce week-end à bercy